okay so I guess I'll start now you know
maybe it looked like I started a while
ago but so this is the this is the
second part of my lecture from yesterday
and let me just start by calling what we
did yesterday also in Yuans lecture so
one of the main things we proved is
something I'm gonna call theorem a which
is a statement about expected
characteristic polynomials of certain
random matrices the random matrices were
sums an independent rank on random
matrices so you have M independent
random vectors R 1 through RM then the
theorem that we proved two things one is
that the expected characteristic
polynomial is real rooted so are our
main thrill routed and in fact we said
well we drive the formula for it and we
said actually this expected
characteristic polynomial only depends
on the covariance matrices of the random
vectors so these AIS are the covariance
matrices of the random vectors and this
this is something that we defined as a
mixed characteristic polynomial so the
first part of the theorem was that these
expected characteristic polynomials are
real rooted the second part of the
theorem which was proved by Yann
essentially is that once you have this
real rootedness statement it allows you
to compare the roots of these expected
characteristic polynomial to eigen
values of the random matrix in other
words roots of the individual
polynomials and in particular we have
that for such a random matrix the
largest eigen value is at most the
largest root of the expected
characteristic polynomial with nonzero
probability okay so not with high
probability or anything but with some
probability it's greater than 0 and yon
showed how you know part 1 this real
rootedness statement implies part 2 via
this interlacing this inductive
interlacing common interlacing argument
that's a summary of the main thing that
yesterday and one of the maybe the main
application was to show existence of
revolution graphs which required an
additional ingredient of bounding the
roots of these polynomials so what I'm
gonna do today is prove one theorem
which I'm gonna call CMB which is a more
quantitative statement that what's shown
here so here we showed that these
polynomials have real roots here B will
give us a bound on the roots of these
polynomials so here is theorem B so if
we have M positive semi definite
matrices we add up to the identity and
have trace bounded by Epsilon then the
mixed characteristic polynomial of these
matrices that's just the polynomial you
get when you look at the expected
characteristic polynomial random vectors
which have those matrices as the
covariance matrices then the largest
root of this polynomial is at most 1
plus squared epsilon over a single
inequality and it's it's it's a generic
bound on the largest roots of such
polynomials and this is the main thing
I'm going to prove today and the main
application of this so are there any
questions about the statement the main
application of this so together theorem
and Theorem be allow you to control the
eigenvalues of these type of random
matrices with nonzero probability
yeah so yeah okay so so we proved the
roots are real the roots are not
negative because it's an average of
polynomials as we return or negative so
the main application is the cancel
singer problem which is equivalent which
okay which is implied by a discrepancy
of theoretic statement known as Weavers
conjecture
so before proving theorem B let me just
tell you how this theorem B implies we
were asked injector and well what
Weavers conjecture is okay The Weavers
conjecture is a question in discrepancy
theory and if you don't know what that
is let me just tell you the you know the
most elementary question in this area
which is discrepancy of set systems so
here's here's sort of the first question
in this area so suppose you're given a
family of subsets and subsets of one
through n well the goal is to find some
signs epsilon 1 up to epsilon n if you
want to think of these as you can think
of these as a coloring of B's out of the
elements of the set or a partition into
two subsets positive and negative such
that
for every one of these sets it's about
it's you know as balanced as possible so
such that the maximum over these subsets
of the some of the signs inside the
subset this quantity so this quantity is
called the discrepancy is small so it
makes sense to call it the discrepancy
you want to think of this as you know
you want to partition these numbers one
to run into two sets in such a way that
for each set almost you know exactly
half is plus and exactly half is minus
and how far you are from being exactly
balanced that's the discrepancy that's a
type of combinatorial problem so this is
a task right that you give me some
subsets I need to find some signs so
that for each subset something happens
you can think of these as test functions
okay so so you know one question is as a
function of n how small do you except
also do you expect this compass here to
be right if I give you an arbitrary set
system can you prove that you can always
do you know at least you know this could
at least some some non-trivial bound so
okay so the first thing to do that the
natural thing to try is to consider a
random signing okay so so what happens
you pick random signs well these are
subsets of n of a set of size n think
they could have size about order n if
you pick random signs inside each subset
you expect about squared and fluctuation
right the variance square right so for
one subset you should get a discrepancy
of squared n but you have n sets so if
you Union bound over them you should
pick up another log factor and so you
can prove that the probability that
there exists some subset with
discrepancy
bigger than about and login I have some
constant this probability is much is
much less than one so random signing
will get your discrepancy root and login
it is sort of very simple way you apply
turn off bound to each set you take a
Union bound you get moved and login so
so that happen that happens with high
probability right so with high
probability you succeed the probability
of failure is small so the interesting
thing is that you can do significantly
better than this okay so so there's a
famous theorem of Spencer 1986 which
says that you can always get discrepancy
less than 6 square then you can beat
this randomized argument for any set
system there exists a coloring which
gets discrepancy significantly less than
this 6 through 10
I won't tell you how the proof works but
it's it's not a rant I mean it uses some
probability but it it doesn't you know
this these good signings are rare and
Spencer's proof shows that nonetheless
that they exist and ok I just want to
mention from an algorithmic point of
view this was proven a long time ago but
it took several decades to show you can
find the signing in polynomial time
that's that's the introduction to one
problem in discrepancy theory a
questions about that so so Weaver's
conjecture is a sort of is this question
you can think of as a spectral
discrepancy theory
and here you're given a set of vectors
instead of a bunch of subsets you're
given a set of vectors and they're
normalized so that the covariance matrix
is the identity so in other words you
know that summation the ivi transpose is
equal to the identity and you know
concretely what this means is that for
every unit vector X the variance in the
X direction of these vectors is 1 so
you're given these vectors the goal is
to again find sign signs one sign for
each vector such that what would you
like to have happen well the original
vectors have the property of the
variance in every direction is one you
would like to find signs so that in
every direction the variance is about
evenly split between the plus and the
minus vectors so the property you want
is such that for every test vector X the
summation epsilon I VI x squared this
quantity is small so let's let's call
this a max
so this is my definition of spectral
discrepancy is more okay so here you had
finitely many tests right for every for
every subset you had a test here you
have infinitely many tests right so for
every vector X on the unit sphere you
get you look at the variance in that
direction and you want to choose the
signs so that this is as small as
possible okay
the variance is evenly split among the
pluses and minuses so that's a that's a
spectral discrepancy type problem now
okay so so so what should you be hoping
for here in discrepancy right so I mean
I told you that the original vectors and
variance one in every direction so at
second moment one in every direction so
trivially I can get one over here right
just by setting all the signs to be one
and in general I actually can't beat one
okay so as stated this problem does not
have an interesting solution because of
this example consider the example where
you're given vectors just a standard
basis so certainly these covariance
matrix equal to the identity but now for
any signing
well the norm is just one right because
this is a diagonal matrix with signs on
the diagonal so certainly I mean okay
this quantity is just a norm maybe I
should write it this way so the norm so
for this example you can't beat one
there's no non-trivial there's nothing
you can do so to make this a sensible
question you have to add one more
condition which is the vectors are not
too long okay so if any of the vectors
are unit vectors you're gonna run into
this problem it doesn't matter what side
you put you're gonna get a normal one so
Weaver's conjecture is let's say you now
throw in the condition that the vectors
are short followed by some constant
Delta which is less than one so you're
right if Delta is small it means that
they're at least they're dis.n over
Delta vectors just by computing traces
so so the vector is being short also
implies that there are many of them okay
so this is a this is a problem which is
parameterized by Delta and for every
Delta you know there there should be
some best discrepancy you can get and
Weavers conjecture is that there exist
some universal constant Delta such that
the discrepancy you can get for that
Delta is strictly less than one so if
you ask that the vectors are
sufficiently short you can always find
the signing that gets you a non-trivial
discrepancy that's bounded away from one
that we were it's conjecture
okay now again you know for this problem
you can try a random signing now
originally in the combinatorial setting
we use the Chernoff bound to analyze a
random signing here this is a random
matrix but there are tools for analyzing
norm of random matrix like this called
the matrix are not bound so matrix
Chernov implies that you know the normal
districts is always bounded by square
root Delta log n so again if you if
you're willing to so you know somehow
pick up this extra log factor you can
solve this problem using standard
probably probabilistic techniques okay
so it's fairly easy to prove that if
you're given vectors so this bound is
meaningless unless Delta is less than 1
over log n if you're given vectors whose
normal is going to 0 as n goes to
infinity like 1 over log n then indeed a
random signing will solve this problem
The Weavers conjecture really is that
there's a constant independent of the
dimension so I mean the reason this is
so important is that this is actually
the statement if you take and if you
transform it in somewhere it take some
appropriate limit you get a solution to
some function analysis problem called
calcine or problem and for that it's
very important that the boundary get
doesn't depend on the demand but even
from a discrepancy theoretic point of
view we're seeing the same phenomenon
here that random gets you some solution
with a log factor can you remove the log
factor yeah yeah it can become an
infinite dimensional statement if there
is no end
so okay so the the theorem that we
proved that we proved a long time ago is
that for any Delta less than 1/4 the
discrepancy is actually less than order
or I mean I guess if you allow order you
don't even get that just two discrepancy
is order root Delta so if you choose
constant rank vectors you can always
solve this problem constant discovery
solve this problem now let me quickly
tell you so are there any questions
about the the statement of the theorem
let me now just tell you how this is how
it's sort of an immediate it's an
immediate consequence of theorem be
or maybe before telling you the proof
let me let me explain to you why this
problem is sort of tricky so let me show
you the two extreme examples that any
proof of this conjecture has to handle
so the first example is let's say I give
you vectors that look like this so I
take the standard basis that does those
vectors have norm one but let's chop it
into vectors which have squared norm
Delta okay so let's make one over Delta
copies of square Delta times the
standard basis in each direction okay
this is a particular instance of this
discrepancy problem so Weaver's problem
for this set of vectors asks well I want
to put pluses and minuses on these
vectors so that you know the norm of the
resulting matrix is small I mean this is
very easy it's this is just you know the
the matrix I'm sorry not you guys the
matrix that you would get in this case
is just a diagonal matrix it's very easy
to control its norm and the appropriate
coloring is just make half plus and half
minus in every direction you actually
get zero if you have even number of
vectors if you do that so in this
example the very simple greedy algorithm
I'll call it works but random fails okay
so if you have a constant number of
these vectors if you do it randomly
you're gonna get all pluses in some
direction
this is a hard example for the matrix
journal phone this is the example where
a random signing fits on the other hand
there's a very different type of example
where the vectors are just random
and on this example it's easier to prove
that random works using some random
matrix theory and greedy I have no idea
how to analyze it right if you give me a
bunch of random vectors and you find try
to find some deterministic algorithm
that partitions them into you know
almost this balance sets I don't have
any I don't know how to do it so this is
somehow the difficulty of the problem
so now you'll now see that theorem B
just doesn't even you know notice this
and just immediately solve this problem
but the point of these examples is to
show that any solution you know must be
somehow with low probability so now
proof of so we're given these vectors
given these are an RN consider the
following random vectors let's make a
random vector RI for each VI
that's just equal to VI 0 or 0 VI times
square 2 with probability 1/2 each
independently ok you gave me this this
discovery problem I constructed a bunch
of independent random vectors then do
something very natural
they either embed this vector a top
block or a smaller block of some vectors
in to n dimensional space
now okay so now you have a random matrix
right of the type that theorems a and B
you talk about so what does this random
matrix look like well it's a block
matrix so there are these two so there's
a two in the front the top block
contains all the vectors that you know
received I don't know let's call this a
plus sign and the bottom block contains
all the vectors are seen the minus sign
that's the random matrix right yes well
that's why I buy two and put half of
them in this block happened over this
month but now the norm of this matrix is
just a norm of this matrix and this is a
block matrix so this is twice the max
over J of the norms of a blocks hey
the random matrix whose norm controls
the norm of you know the maximum of the
norms of the pluses and the minuses now
what does serum theorems a plus B what
do they tell us they tell us that with
nonzero probability this norm which is
the largest eigenvalue of this semi
definite of other seven different matrix
this is at most a 1 plus square root
epsilon squared where what epsilon
epsilon is the maximum trace of any of
these covariance matrices
and these are easy to compute right
because these vectors are they have
squared northmost Delta so each of these
covariance matrices will have trace at
most two Delta
so theorem a tells you you can compare
this to the expected characteristic
polynomial theorem B tells you the
expected characteristic polynomial has
roots bounded by this quantity okay
theorem B also had an additional
condition which you have to verify which
is that the sum of the covariance
matrices is the identity that's easy to
verify right so the if you look at the
expectation of this matrix you'll just
get twice times identity over two
identity over two so these were the
conditions of theorem B I verified them
theorem B implies this bound on the norm
this is one plus square root two Delta
squared
now why is this good
well this is good because this means
that look at the sum of the vectors in
each of these sets
well the norm of this is half the norm
of this big matrix norm of four one of
these heads will be one plus square root
two Delta
but now this is actually true for both
the set and its complement number
because I've partitioned my vectors
which add up to the identity set and so
what that means is well if the
eigenvalues of this are upper bounded
and the eigenvalues of the complement
are propounded complemental like
identity minus the matrix of 400 I also
get a lower bound okay and so now if I
just take the difference I get the bound
that I want so it's it's it's an
immediate consequence of this theorem a
and B which gives you a dimension free
bound on the norm of a random matrix of
this time okay so any questions about
that
okay okay so now I'll just spend the
rest of the time explaining the proof of
theorem be so so theorem B is a
statement that if you give me a bunch of
matrices positive semi-definite adding
up to the identity and with bounded
trace epsilon then the mixed
characteristic polynomial has a bounded
root right so largest root of the mixed
characteristic polynomial squared okay
so the strategy relies on an exercise
from yesterday which some people did so
this this this polynomial we derived we
observed this is a univariate polynomial
we observed it's a restriction of a
certain multivariate polynomial so we
derived a formula for this polynomial it
was 1 minus product of 1 minus part of
the 1 plus partial Zi
determinant of X I - okay
so
so so our goal is to control the zeros
of this of a polynomial like this
so it's gonna be slightly more
convenient to rewrite this again by
doing a simple change of variables so
I'm gonna replace Z with minus Z that
will slip these signs and I'll use the
fact that summation of zi AI of sorry
summation x AI is equal to x times
identity I've observed the vectors add
up the rank one matrices add up to the
identity so if I use this fact and do a
little change of variables this
polynomial is actually equal to product
of 1 minus partial I so I'm gonna write
partial I for partial Z I of determinant
nation's VII when you restrict all the
variables to be just equal to X my goal
is to show that under these analytic
assumptions on the matrices AI I can
bound the roots of that polynomial by 1
plus squared epsilon squared so this
polynomial well it consists of did you
know determinant sort of relatively
simple determinant determinant of
polynomial like this whose eros I can
actually understand right so I can think
of this problem as simple why well
so let's call this polynomial Q naught
okay so I can easily identify a large
zero free region for Q naught and get an
upper bound on the zeros of its
restriction along X Y well observe that
the set K naught which is the set of all
in RN so the summation Zi AI is positive
definite okay so this is a section of a
positive semi-definite code this is a
zero free region I mean if this matrix
is positive definite this polynomial is
not zero and so its restriction is not
zero either it's easy to understand zero
free regions for this polynomial the
whole game is well what happens to this
to this this cone what happens to the
zero free region when you apply these
differential operators
okay so strategy is to understand
perturbation of zeros great perturbation
of zero free regions under these
differential operators
okay so that's what I'm now gonna
explain how to do
okay so rather than diving straight into
this that how do you understand the
zeros perturbation of zeros of these
multivariate polynomials I'm first going
to show you how to understand
perturbation of univariate polynomials
so you can think of this as a warm-up
for the actual task of controlling the
zeros of this polynomial so let's
suppose I have a real rooted polynomial
P of X and let's say I now subtract off
its derivative that's the kind of thing
I'm interested in doing so I'm gonna use
this partial notation pedagogically nice
later so 1 minus partial P is actually
just P minus P Prime and you know in
general if you actually care about this
if you look at the largest root and you
subtract the derivative it can move
around a lot it can you know you can't
prove good worst case bounds on it
because for example consider this
polynomial consider X to the N minus its
derivative well that's X to the N minus
NX n to the minus 1 that has a 0 at n so
just by subtracting the derivative once
you increase the largest root by n okay
so it doesn't really make sense to prove
worst case bounds on large 0 it's very
unstable if the largest 0 has high
multiplicity
okay so maybe the point of this is that
zeros can be unstable
and so the idea is well instead of
looking at the zeros you look at some
smoother quantity which can upper bound
the zeros key object in controlling
zeros under these types of perturbations
is the following rational function that
I'm gonna call the barrier function
although it's like a hundreds of years
old object so V P of X is a rational
function that's going to be derivative
of P divided by P okay let's assume the
polynomial is monic this is on the
univariate case I'll tell you what I'm
switching to the multivariate case so so
what is this well it's a rational
function whose poles are just the zeros
of the polynomial so let's say it has
zeros lambda 1 to lambda n okay and okay
I mean this is also just the derivative
of log P
okay so what does this look like well to
rational function as I mentioned whose
poles are at the zero so the zeros are
like this then this is a rational
function that looks like this
and one sort of one obvious thing is
that the zeroes of P correspond to the
poles of the barrier function that's
obvious the interesting thing from the
point of view of these differential
operators is that this barrier function
actually also tells you the zeroes of P
- its derivative why well let's say you
look at the level set where the barrier
function which is just P equals 1 so
let's say you look at the set of points
they're not poles but the set of points
where the barrier function is equal to 1
well if derivative of P divided by P
equals 1 if you rearrange this just just
means P - its derivative is equal to 0
right so actually this rational function
encodes the locations of zeroes of P -
all multiples of its derivatives just by
looking at these level sets so so zeroes
of P - its derivative correspond to a
point where this barrier function is
equal to 1 as opposed to infinity
okay
in fact you can you can use this
observation to prove upper bounds on the
locations of the zeros by studying you
don't need to find a point where it's
exactly equal to one by just finding a
point where the barrier function is
sufficiently small so here's the
observation so if you have some number
that's bigger than the largest root of a
real rooted polynomial P and you know
that the barrier function of P at this
point is strictly less than one then
actually this point has to be bigger
than the largest root of P - what's the
proof of this observation well to prove
this observation is we have the the
largest root of so this is the largest
root of P maybe I use a different color
this is the largest root of P - its
derivative well the key point is that
this function is monotone decreasing
above the largest root of P that's I
mean that's easy to check so once you're
above the largest root of P this is a
monitor on decreasing functions that
means if you found some other point
let's say some point B here where the
value of the barrier function is less
than one it has to be bigger than the
largest fruit so if you can find such a
point that gives you an upper bound on P
- P so that's how you that's how you
understand perturbation of the roots of
a polynomial under one of these
operators any questions on that
yeah but no this is this isn't really
good enough because what about what if I
had what if I did this a bunch of times
but my actual polynomial I'm interested
in I mean if if this is in any way
related to that involves applying a
whole bunch of these operators this
argument is not gonna get me very far
right so I start off with P okay I
calculate I somehow calculated barrier
function I find I find a point where
it's less than 1 that gives me an upper
bound on the largest fruit of this
perturbation but then what do I do
right I mean I can't apply this
inductively because I don't know
anything about the barrier function of
this polynomial so ideally what I need
is a robust version of this which
relates the barrier function of the
polynomial to the barrier function of
the perturbation and then I can induct
so this is a robust version of this
lemma and here's what it says so this
was proven in a paper with bats and
Spielman essentially in 2008 and what
this says is the following so if P of X
is real rooted and you have a point
that's above the largest root of P
and not only is it about largest Rafi
you have some control on the barrier
function at this point then you have
something better than one
so here the observation you said if the
barrier function is less than one that
gives you an upper bound here I'm asking
the barrier function is less than 1
minus 1 over Delta Delta is some number
that's positive number that's bigger
than 1 then B plus Delta is bigger than
the largest root of B minus its
derivative and you get the same you you
actually get control on the barrier
function of the new polynomial at this
point C of B minus its derivative at B
plus Delta is less than
okay so it's okay maybe this is a bit
this is a lot to to handle but the way
to conceptualize it is this point a
point B which satisfies this property a
point that's above the roots of a
polynomial and and the barrier function
is bounded I'm thinking of that as a
delta robust upper bound okay so instead
of looking at this upper bounds on the
roots I'm gonna look at upper bounds
where this function is fall and I
intuitively those are points that are
that are actually stable under these
perturbations they're very in a smooth
way
well the theorem is saying is exactly
that if you find a delta robust upper
bound then B plus Delta is a delta
robust upper bound for P minus its
derivative sorry I'm sorry 1 minus
partial no this is 1 minus 1 over 2 out
that's right
what minus 1 over Delta okay so you're
asking what's the intuition you recover
this for Delta equals infinity right ok
so so so so in this case all you know is
it's less than 1 so Delta could be huge
right that makes sense because think
about this example so here ok wait
I'm sorry this statement is for any
Delta for any Delta bigger than one I
mean okay for Delta less than 1 this is
negative for any Delta bigger than 1
this I mean right if this is less than 1
you get this for free and this statement
doesn't say anything about the very
function ok so I think the point is the
conclusion here is stronger right so the
point is I'm taking this whole thing as
a conclusion and you're right this does
not recover this because here the
conclusion is weaker I'm not asking
anything for the barrier function here
only for being larger than the largest
root you're right if you take Delta to
be infinity you don't get anything here
but that's not because of this part it's
because of this part
okay another way of putting this is this
has a this is stronger hypothesis and a
stronger conclusion it's not it's not a
generalization of this thing but above
hey this is a stronger hypothesis this
is a stronger conclusion this is a Delta
robust upper bound on P and this is a
delta robust around P - its riveted and
now this is good because you can induct
if you have a lemma like this you can
you can start with some polynomial you
can start with the Delta robust upper
bound on its roots for some
appropriately chosen value of Delta so
so let's say this is your b1 and you
know that fee of P is less than then
some value that you set so 1 minus 1
over Delta and now the point is that
when you apply this differential
operator this will move by Delta to get
some value b2 and you'll have exactly
the same induction hypothesis here that
fee of P minus partial P is less than 1
minus 1 over Delta you can continue
doing this every time you just move by
Delta what this is trying to articulate
is if instead of looking at if instead
of looking at the roots you look at you
know these particular level sets of this
function they move smoothly we all yeah
so this is weaker than this yeah
so ok so that's exactly Pablo's question
right so I mean this is just because you
know this doesn't I mean I need this as
part of the assumption if you're working
inside the eigen value somewhere none of
this makes any sense right because it
could be negative and stuff like that
it's just no no no I'm just trying to
yeah ok any other questions
this doesn't have any like hidden tricks
doesn't have any hidden track so let me
show you the proof
so I can let me show you proof on this
slide popping these what's the proof
well okay
so I have some polynomial PD and I have
some point above its roots and I know
something about its barrier function I
want to know something about the barrier
function of polynomial - its derivative
at a point that's now a little bit
bigger my goal is I mean my goal is to
prove mainly this inequality then this
follows easily from some continuity
argument okay okay so let's just write
down what this is well the first thing
to observe is to observe the P - its
derivative is just P times 1 minus its
barrier function that's just from the
definition
well that means is that this new barrier
function is the derivative of P minus
derivative which is P times 1 minus V of
P
/ P times 1 minus V F P now I waited at
this point because that's just the
definition now if I just differentiate
this I get two terms so the first term
the piece cancel and I get a minus or so
minus the derivative of the barrier
function 1 minus the value of the
barrier function the second term I get
derivative of P over P which is
just the barrier function itself again
evaluated at the point B + Delta and
what I want
is I want this to be less than the
original barrier function of the
original polynomial at the point P
and I'm gonna make two observations
which I mean I guess I erased them but
they follow from the picture of the
rational function so let me write them
here
so one is that this function is monotone
decreasing above the roots of the
polynomial Sophie P P - and this follows
from from this picture right here it's
monotone decreasing here suppose you
were at B over here if you go to be plus
Delta you get something strictly smaller
what that means is that well this
quantity is just C of P that means if I
rearrange this inequality this means I
can rearrange this inequality to get
it's all I did is I move this to the
other side and took it under the
denominator and move this up and the
reason I could do that is it's a
positive it's a non-negative number we
want to prove it we still want to prove
it yeah so we want okay so this is a
statement we want and I'm claiming that
this table we want is implied by this
statement it's actually equivalent and I
use monotonicity here because I need a
positivity of the denominator to
rearrange it in this way now I'm gonna
use one more property so I'm gonna use
monetary again to say well a stronger
statement would be to replace this by a
smaller number so I can replace this by
1 minus P P of P or maybe I'll put the
arrow here and now I'm going to use one
more property which is convexity so
so this function is convex is also
convex above the largest root it's not
just monitor it's also convex that means
that if I care about this difference
which is what appears in the denominator
here it's gonna be at most what I would
get if I took the linear approximation
with this tangent regular I can this
inequality is implied by an inequality I
gotta fireplaces buy a smaller quantity
which is a linear approximation so this
is implied by the inequality minus the
same thing but now I replace this with
the linear approximation what is the
linear approximation well it says that
value of the barrier function at B minus
the value of the barrier function this
is at least Delta x minus the derivative
that means I can now replace this by
delta x - so these are all in B plus
Delta
but now these cancel you get one over
Delta less than one minus a potential
which is the assumption in the theorem I
guess I shouldn't have erased a
statement of the theorem but the
assumption in the theorem was that the
potential is less than 1 minus 1 over
Delta okay that's the entire proof it's
just these four lines now the reason I
showed you this is not because I want to
do some annoying calculations it's
because I want to show you that the
proof of the multivariate thing is
almost the same so any questions about
this before I move to the multivariate
so multivariate multivariate case I have
a real stable polynomial and I don't
have roots right I have some variety of
zeros zeros that are not discrete so
what I'm gonna be interested in as an
upper bound on the root is the following
set it's gonna be the set of points such
that when you look at the polynomial and
you look at an orphaned what with the
corner at that point then the polynomial
is nonzero so the picture is something
like I have a polynomial like this it
has some zeros I'm interested in KP is
the set of all points X so that when you
look at this or send the polynomials
down to you
that's my notion of an upper bound on
the roots
now I'm going to be interested in
tracking the movement of these sets as I
apply differential operators let me the
new writing I want to keep all this so
that's my notion of upper bound and I'm
gonna have a notion of barrier function
this is gonna be again a rational
function given a real stable polynomial
the barrier function in the is
coordinate at a point Z is partial IP
over P evaluate it so Z is now a vector
is a vector they defined this where I
goes from 1 to M
okay so there are two there are two
lemmas about this so lemma one is that
this function so this is some rational
function that's defined in RN but if I
look at what it does inside this cone
it's gonna have very nice analytic
properties that's what allows this proof
to go through the first lemma is if I
look at the multivariate barrier
functions at any point yeah okay maybe
I'll write it like this so if you have a
point that's above the roots of a real
stable polynomial then if you look at
the function you look at the barrier
function any of these barrier functions
in a direction any of the coordinate
direction so this is a univariate
function is monotone and convex
okay so if you look inside this cone
these barrier functions are literally
what you get if you restrict all the
variables and look at the barrier
function along one direction the claim
is that these are monotone and convex
but not just in the direction that the
barrier function is defined in but in
all the coordinate directions and using
this you can prove lemma two which is a
word almost verbatim it's almost the
same as the lemma I proved earlier in
the univariate case and it's the
following if you have a point that above
the roots of a multivariate polynomial
I'm sorry if if P is stable B is above
the root and is multivariate barrier
functions
I rounded by 1 minus 1 over Delta then a
plus Delta now let's make this J then B
plus Delta AJ so so this is all about
what happens when I perturb the
polynomial with a different differential
operator 1 minus partial J this is above
the roots of P minus partial j AP so
that's the point
I can relate the cone for P 2 the cone
for P minus partial JP and none of these
potential blow up so P sub I be a plus
so it's it's it's syntactically almost
identical to what I wrote in the
univariate case except the picture is
different so I've replaced replaced
single just a usual derivative by
partial derivative and now I have to
move this upper bound in space I don't
it's not just a number I don't just move
it up yes
oh I'm sorry B minus partial JP yeah so
so the picture associated with this is
you know I had my real stable polynomial
I had some upper bound B and now once I
one side if once I subtract the
derivative in Direction J I have to move
this up B plus Delta e hi EJ and the
claim is that if I do that
none of these potential functions
increase you can but I'm just stating it
this way you can replace EJ by any
positive vector so it's actually convex
in the horse and marginal convex no okay
so now the proof of lemma 2 is pretty
much already in the board let me just
show you that the same proof works
assuming lemma 1 assuming more atrocity
and connected okay so what's the proof
lemma two well okay this still works
right if I subtract off the J it's
partial I just it's like multiplying by
the J its barrier function okay so now
I'm interested in the is barrier
function of the polynomial perturbed in
the J direction so the induction to work
I need to control all of the barrier
function that's the subtlety and now I'm
interested in it at the but I'm now I'm
moving my barrier by in the in the J
direction up shown in that picture okay
so let's just follow our notes right so
you get a partial I because this is a
barrier function direction I
perturbation is in Direction J so you
get J's here and now here this works the
same way you get partial I J's barrier
function this is still a J here you get
the is partial sorry and you want this
to be less than the is barrier function
of P at be
so this is exactly I mean I'm just
writing out the new barrier function of
the perturb polynomial at the new point
and relating it to the barrier function
of the original polynomial the original
point so again by lemma 1 I have
monotonicity of the if' barrier function
in the J direction
ok so this is still true so I can still
do this rearrangement and I will get the
same thing
so this J goes to the other side okay
and now to do the final cancelation I
need convexity but I also have that
right so I have convexity of the if'
barrier function in the J direction so
now I'll get a partial I feed J okay but
now something funny happens here I get a
I'm sorry partial JPI alright partial J
yes I'm moving in the J direction the
denominator I get a partial J Fei in the
numerator I have a partial i fe j
otherwise everything else is the same
okay but also I feit a is partial a
partial J log B and partial derivatives
commute so it's actually the same as
partial J Fei this is the one sort of
one minor difference in the proof but
then you cancel these in the same it's
the same proof it's a like five line
proof main ingredient is establishing
monitors here this monitor is in
convexity is I won't have time to
explain how it's done so I'll just state
what tools are used but are there any
questions before that so when you
replace this function f fine right -
it's never sharp I become a sharp and
the roots to the right bird oh what's
never sharp oh you mean this yeah this
is okay so in here as standard this can
never be sharp right because if I
actually wanted B to be at a root this
would have to be infinity right and I'm
insisting that Delta is bigger than one
which inequality is becoming so the
convexity oh yeah sure the convexity
equality is becoming sharper zero goes
to infinity this function is becoming
linear okay anyway yeah I guess that's I
mean I think I'm already considerably
over time so let me just
so the key thing is to prove lemma 1
which is monotonicity and convexity and
then the univariate proof works there's
a monitor necessary to theorems that I
think will be discussed in the world
from there are two options one is the
health and vinegar theorem which says
that by variant restrictions of real
stable polynomials are determinants and
the second is convexity properties of
the function log P in the set KP which
is actually the hyperbola cone of the of
the polynomial P and this this this can
this follows from results in hyperbolic
optimization okay but I guess I don't
have time to talk about it but the only
new thing you need is these monetary and
convexity that's how you can use either
ya or okay I guess
any questions it's almost time do we
have total yeah have you ever take a
five-minute break
we have an open problem thing - right
yeah